what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey from podcast
one
this is unwaxed get in loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone
we just become best friends yep
hello everybody welcome
back to another episode of the unwax
podcast with your two favorite sisters
once again sophia and sistine stallone
you guys we have had quite the busy week
i love an exciting weekend quarantine
because i feel like finally
some fun things have happened that we
can share with you
i think we should start with sophia's
birthday i
turned 24. i actually was so
stressed out turning 24 this year why
because i feel like it's an
older it's an old it's 24 sounds older
i mean not old as an old old but
everyone above 24 is listening to this
like shut the [ __ ] up
correct no but i'm i'm happy i'm 24. it
does just sound a little bit more mature
definitely feel like i'm 18 still is
there anything
in your year of being 24 that you wish
to accomplish
well other than this podcast becoming
super successful
i really want to start traveling more on
my own with
like friends even you you can come along
wait traveling on your own or with
friends
both i mean either either on my own i
can't go alone anywhere
i would be so sad eating alone walking
alone
but then it's like self-discovery but i
also don't need to just
you don't need to go to guatemala to
find yourself sophia
uh okay fine if anyone wants to go with
me to guatemala to find themselves
okay buy me a ticket so it was sophia's
24th birthday
yeah we did a fun little beach day yeah
we did a little social distance
friend group thing in malibu it was good
we had my sister though oh wait we
have to say this funny story we went to
um
we went to get drinks for your birthday
yeah oh on my actual day we went
to get dinner and drinks and then on
saturday we went yeah and i have to tell
this story do you remember that one guy
that came up to us
there was just one guy with this weird
bandana
and he comes up and he goes is it
someone's birthday you know that classic
cliche
and i'm like and sophia goes yeah and he
goes how old are you turning she goes 24
and he goes
oh and turns around and walks
he fully just walked away we're like bye
bandana man
yeah and we called him bandana man the
whole night because he then he kept
coming back up like trying to weasel his
way but i just thought it was funny i'm
like i'm too old for you that's
that was the moment i was like oh god am
i old is he look
are guys like now looking at me as a
sophia you're basically like
it's horrible you're a mummy i'm a mummy
i'm rotting right now but we went to
malibu yeah and it was super fun we had
a bunch of friends there
um we blasted some music we drank in the
afternoon
you don't ever feel good after you drink
in the afternoon yeah because when it
night hits you i feel like i was
cleaning up trash the whole time while
you were drinking and having fun yeah
totally it's fine another exciting thing
that happened this week
is my dad caught
a four foot rattlesnake on
our front staircase like right in front
of our house oh no
guys huge rattle snake and let me tell
you how he caught it
with a polo club uh
how so we have little dogs caught it or
killed it no no he didn't kill him no he
didn't kill it
but we have these two little cava poos
and if this snake
the snake was basically in their
territory where they play every day
it was no no it was on our front door
let me break it down
i'm in bed melatonin consumed i'm i'm in
and out phasing but you know when you
have a gut feeling that something is
not right and you can't sleep for that
reason it was that
so i was up at 11 30. way past my 10 30
bedtime
way back and i hear the strange noise
outside i'm like hmm i'm going to
investigate right
i look out the window and i see sly
with a giant six-foot polo club
like poking this poking this rattlesnake
to like get it away
and i was like all you hear is shh
the whole time i could not believe how
stupid he was
because he didn't realize that you know
a snake can lunge at you
and his reasoning for using the polo
stick was because it's
long enough that maybe it won't touch
him he also said there was nothing else
around and i'm like
maybe next time we just let it be yeah
just maybe like call animal control have
someone pick it up well that was
exciting
that was exciting that stressed me out
but you i didn't get to watch it this
morning but you got to watch
david blaine's ascension
will did you see it i have not seen it
oh
i'm not kidding you i nearly wet the bed
i'm not just
like there's so when you are
watching from his point of view he was
up like
what was it like sixteen thousand crazy
like that
it was absolutely absurd he was at a
temperature where it was one degree
celsius i mean the conditions were
insane he kept saying
to um the people that were talking him
on the floor they were like you need
oxygen
you need oxygen you're in you're in an
airplane air zone you need oxygen he
goes
i'm fine i've dealt with this force and
then you're not no and then he's talking
to his daughter
i'm saying i was like oh my god because
she's french and she's the sweetest
little girl ever but
just even that your dad is up in the air
if that anything could happen you could
fall to his death and you're talking to
your little girl
the whole time too he was so calm
yeah he never got nervous he never broke
his his serious focusness like it was
unbelievable i think we should start a
conspiracy theory that he isn't human
like he must he must be like
extraterrestrial wizard wizard
i mean i'm not serious about lizard
people he probably
that's a conspiracy theory i'm gonna
bring up but he isn't human
because no one can physically do that no
one gonna have no fear
to i mean the things he's done he's was
submerged underwater for
multiple days he's been in ice he's held
his breath he's
poked his arm with an ice pack no he's
just he's unbelievable and
over the years we've gotten quite close
with him he's come over a lot
and he is one of the kindest human
beings and he was telling us about this
stunt maybe about a year ago right and
the training that would go into it
and his idea and he was supposed to do
in new york city which would have been
incredible but because of winds and
temperatures they didn't allow it
but we were just warning him david
please don't
you don't need to do it like this this
trick could actually end in death
like yeah you shot yourself in the face
but like this seems scarier you know
what
i
completely forgot that he was doing this
trick until we got that package
in the mail it was a giant giant box and
we opened it up and it was these massive
balloons that just came out i'm like oh
my god he's
going in an air balloon basically so
spoiler alert i know this is going to
come out like a week later
he's okay he actually landed on his feet
perfectly
it was unbelievable skydiving it was a
moment it was crazy
yeah so i feel like we should talk about
who we're having on today which we're
super super pumped about
i sort of feel like i already know her
because her presence on social media is
so
engaging and she's so likable and warm
and she owns it and just listening to
her kind of gives you more confidence in
yourself even though she's saying all
the words like hell yeah i gotta
get out there and get it but she's i'm
really excited to hear what she has to
bring
yeah she's definitely gonna drop some
facts on us so yeah
okay you guys today we have
the queen of confidence herself she is a
creator
and a host of instagram's first reality
dating show
she's a confidence coach a blogger and
i'm just scratching the surface with her
list of accomplishments
we have the multi-talented serena
[ __ ] kerrigan
okay so i really just want to ask this
question right off the bat
did you really change your middle name
to [ __ ] well like if you believe if
you had to ask the question
then like no i oh i was like you like
me no i didn't i didn't do that that
would make my parents would actually
actually tell me
um but i told everyone i did and they
believed it but actually my middle name
starts with an a
that's all i'll tell you which would
mean my initial spell sack
so like oh oh you're like i gotta change
it it doesn't work for not brand new
this is like not it's not on brand so i
just tell everyone it's talking
when did you start telling people your
middle name was [ __ ]
when i got to college i went to duke and
i was like i got to campus
and i was like ugh like i felt really
insecure
and but i love to be the center of
attention and like i just felt like was
like i felt super invisible
yeah and i was like and i at that time
it's like i feel sad for the old me but
like i
really felt like i wasn't like good
looking enough like what but whatever
i didn't because that's normal and so i
was like
what is a way to grab people's attention
that like has something to do with my
looks
and i was like i'm just trying to
introduce myself a string of [ __ ]
kerrigan and let me tell you
people were like what is there something
about the word because it is really
aggressive and i feel like for
a woman today to say oh my god my middle
name's [ __ ] just comes off so
um do you know what i mean like it just
it sounds so aggressive like is there
something about the word that you're
just like
this is what i want people to see i
think that's part of the reason why like
at every moment of my life
like my mom my dad my
agent manager sorority girls
like you know god my guy friends were
like no guys didn't want to go with you
like you're never getting a sorority
like but it's like every
moment i think people like were
protected because they were like it is
like
for a woman to say that like yeah like
god forbid right
yeah and not yeah and not only does
it obviously have a shock factor behind
it but there is something to be said
about
saying the word and saying your name
like if i was saying sophia [ __ ]
stallone i'd definitely build up some
type of like
confidence in myself after a while like
okay i'm the [ __ ]
or i did that happen to you because even
though you started it out just
trying to get the attention grab but now
you're just like wait
this is i'm owning this totally so i
it everything you're saying 100 and by
the way if a guy was like i'm joe
[ __ ] schmoe no one would think twice
about it but when i did it it was like
suddenly like the most oh my god of
course
so and you're 100 right i mean like i
feel
like in the beginning it was to get
people's attention but what it really
was was for me to walk into a room be
like you're screwing a [ __ ] kerrigan
like
hell yeah like you're a bad [ __ ] like
go up to that guy like ask him how he's
doing you know what i mean so like
that was such a good reminder and then
as i
got older serena and sfk kind of became
one
though it is like a fun person i play
right but what i realized what it was
like i
i have i can use this what i learned
from this which is like anyone can
tap into that like inner sfk and you 10
minutes before an interview or like
after a date or what they could just
like be like
no like you got this believe in yourself
i totally agree there are so many
sort of semi-drunken nights where i'm
looking in a bathroom man i'm like
you're a bad [ __ ] you [ __ ] own the
room
you're hot you look good now go out
there and do it and i'm like
it's true i feel like saying that mantra
before actually makes the world's
difference
why do you think that my focus is a
mirror yes
see arena and it's like it's
affirmations it's telling yourself i
mean yeah people go like look at
yourself in the mirror and say you're
beautiful you're amazing
it's just which is great to do and
sometimes i do it but when it comes to a
term like that can be
kind of aggressive or something that's a
shock factor that
really gets me pumped and that's how you
should approach every situation whether
it's a job a date
even just like looking at yourself in
the morning i mean it's 100
and i also feel like you know the whole
like
affirmation thing like didn't really
work for me like i just
love myself not my vibe
right so i was like no like i'm going to
hype you up
the way i'm going to hype up my best
friend the way it hit you guys up you're
like this podcast [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
amazing like i love
it right like yeah we do that to
everyone yeah obviously
to ourselves so true so true and so
speaking of
[ __ ] let's talk about let's [ __ ]
date
your show wow cysteine and i were
stalking
the [ __ ] out of this thing and we were
unbelievably impressed it's
so fun to watch i love i mean we love
talking about dating and sex and
romance and things and just watching a
live date happen especially with you who
have such
confidence and like you really call out
these guys you really have these great
customers so sort of
sort of explain to our listeners a
little bit about the concept of your
show
yeah so it's called let's [ __ ] date
it was march in lockdown new york city
my roommate left like my parents are
uptown i didn't want to see them because
i didn't want to get them sick i was
fully alone
single as [ __ ] which is great but i was
like
okay so like this is going to be like
for a while like i need to figure out
what is like the solution here yes yeah
i you know everyone was going live on
instagram
and i have a lot of experience producing
for live content so i was like
what if i just like went on a date and
it just happened to be live
um and for three yeah like said
literally no one
right like literally no one but okay
uh sure uh and literally for three
months i just went on
two dates every friday night but we're
proceeding to we're switching it to
wednesdays because
there's like a bit of going out now i
don't know but like walk down it was
like
fridays were the night that like i would
black out so like i was like i need
something to like i need to enjoy
myself like so what it did was like we
went live
every friday 8 30 and um i would go on
two back-to-back dates
live and because of the instagram live
feature people can comment during the
day that's right
it was like a party every like every
weekend i
totally forgot about people saying like
dump him or leave i mean what's like
what are some of the crazy comments that
come up during your life
oh my no no it's they literally like
they honestly get to play god in a way
in terms of
these what dating show have you ever
watched where you get to tell the girl
like
asking if he has a tattoo there's none
none what time is he born
i would have loved to be on dates where
the guy was not worth
my while and i wouldn't have a friend to
say like hey like leave him or
hey he's kind of suss here like that's a
bad answer is there any common trend
with going out with these guys
that you saw because dating is hard
today yeah
uh no it was like this is the thing like
the one thing about the show that i
really wanted to establish
too is that i feel like on a lot of the
shows that we see
people villainize people very quickly
you know horrible like we've seen like
a lot of people get cancelled yep you
know and i was like just because a guy
isn't good
for me doesn't mean he's a bad guy right
and i wanted to establish that pretty
quickly so at the beginning of the
episode i'm always like being nice in
the comments but i'm like
wait because they're not gonna be like
they're they're having fun yeah guys
yeah but there's definitely been moments
where like i'm
oh i mean listen like i'm paying
attention to the guy i'm on the date
right i'm also like the host of the show
i'm reading the comments text from my
producer i'm like
it's like literally sensory overload
it's so crazy but it's so fun yeah do
you think that
do you prefer doing this form of dating
because if you don't like the guy you
can simply just
hang up or end the live so i'm glad you
brought that up because i went
on a date last week that i was like i
literally met him on an app and
i was like let's facetime before because
i think that everyone should be assigned
before because like
i agree barley listen sophia doesn't
facetime i'm a big face timer i'll
facetime you without telling you i'm
about to facetime you catch you off
guard
i agree why don't you face time i i
don't know i like calling more and i
don't we're fine
you know i'm also very picky so
right off the bat if i'm not interested
in him or like find something off i
won't go on the date and i like to give
the benefit of the doubt
so that's why i try to avoid it that's
fair which is actually by the way what
all the dates on my show are blind
like i like i literally knew nothing
that's awesome
no i know it's it's it's actually insane
i'm like oh hello
so are you my husband like maybe like
quite literally no i literally end the
season when i was like people like who's
the winner and i was like
myself myself serena [ __ ] kerrigan
won
but i think that i went on a date last
week and like i was like want to
facetime before and he was like ah it
could be tomorrow and i was like you
know what
[ __ ] it like i'm about to do another
season of my show like let me just like
do it within the first five minutes i
was like i should have facetimed you
before because i knew it wasn't a match
and you
know very quickly oh yeah and i think
it's important to normalize
the phone call or the facetime before i
totally agree
what's a telling sign for you that
you're like no not for me
okay i need a man i think you know
oh yeah like this guy was like oh like
[Laughter]
[ __ ] love bug light french fries and
i was like okay so like how about like a
charcuterie like and like a male back
no like something like that he's still
in like
lambda say kai like you're in a flat you
still go to college or high school which
one
graduates he thinks lunchables are
charcuterie
thank you yeah so i totally get that
so i actually want to go into a
different gear and we want to talk about
rejection
because i think you've mentioned before
that you
quit your job or were you fired by am i
no no
i quit on my own afford mm-hmm so you've
got quite a bit we've all been rejected
before from a lot of things so yeah
i feel like sophia and i we talk a lot
about rejection with guys on the show
but we don't really talk about rejection
with like life so you quit your job you
were a video producer at refinery29 for
like
four years i did some good stalking okay
and you totally bet on yourself like you
decided to take a chance on you
build your empire sfk and
were there moments along the way that
like people you know gave you their
unwarranted opinions and telling you
like doubting you
like what was that like for you uh yeah
your whole life everyone's gonna doubt
you everyone's gonna say you can't do
something everyone's gonna underestimate
you
that's part of life it's really their
own insecurities and they're projecting
them on you
it's about them usually so i wanted to
quit my job i talked to a lot of people
and they're like
what what do you mean you're gonna quit
like what are you gonna do how are you
gonna make money and
i was like um i'm going to [ __ ]
succeed
so that's just the only option you've
got you just have that mindset though
because i feel like a lot of people
can't get to that point of just saying
screw i know i'm going to succeed this
is what my passion is let me go for it
well i think
it's really about being very clear about
what you want so i've always known from
a very young age i wanted to perform i
wanted to be famous
i literally don't know why it was just
like i said it when i was like four
times like i want to be famous but i i
found a way
to do it in a way that's also giving
back which i think is right of course
it's always been very clear and i'd say
to anyone like write down
like taking realism and reality and your
parents opinions or anyone's being what
would you want what does your dream like
life look like i literally have a
notebook on my desk it's like house in
the hamptons
covered vogue like i'm just [ __ ] like
i will get to all those things
like without i said i want my tv show
and i want to start a company and i did
it in six months that's incredible i
think wow
really being clear about what you want
and if you believe in yourself
you will make it happen and yes so along
the way people are going to give you
unwarranted opinions or tell you no
you can't pay attention to anyone but
that goal that you wrote down
just focus on what's ahead of you and
what you can control and there's a lot
of moments in my life where i've been
rejected
you know opportunities jobs guys
whatever and i always look at it like
this like
it's it's literally just like it is such
a redirection
it's it's it doesn't feel like it in the
moment you're like what
yeah but like for example i got ghosted
on an app once
i was like literally a huge mistake like
worst of your life
but then i was like on and i was like
kind of a little like bummed about it
but then i was like wait like
i want someone who is a hundred percent
in yeah
yes everything happens for a reason no
you're like okay this guy doesn't want
me or this job doesn't want me or this
person doesn't want me in their life
why would i want to be in theirs so
you're really good at keeping
your blinders on and you're exiting out
all of the noise around you
but was there ever a moment through this
six month
i'm not even say six months because this
has been like a journey for you
that you doubted yourself or did you
sort of just
take the fear face it head on and you're
like [ __ ] you i'm going for it
to the fear of course oh absolutely i
doubt myself
and also it's hard when you you know
comparison
happens a lot and it's the biggest waste
of time
ever yeah you're never going to be
anyone and but no one gets to be you
right which is like sick tea like no one
gets to be us
like even like with my dating show i
noticed a lot of people started live
dating shows like but you know what like
i was like and obviously sometimes i was
like whoa like way to just
take my idea but i was like first of all
this is not that original and second of
all i'm just kidding
no it's super original i was the first
one copying is the
biggest form of flattery so no right and
also like but they never they're never
gonna have me
as the star of the year so yeah they
might have a show
it might succeed but they don't have
what makes my show mine which is me and
i think that if you think in that aspect
it's like super important
and then in terms of self-doubt
self-doubt it's like a way to calculate
risk
it's like we're you know it's like
flight or flight fight or flight right
so it's like
should we do this but i always say what
is the worst thing that can happen i
quit my job and i don't make it
okay well i worked at refineries for
four years i'm in production i'm smart
i'm social
i have a network i'll [ __ ] figure it
out so if you always think what is worse
than i can
it's not that scary right ever it's
really true when you actually
put in perspective and you question a
lot of the things that we worry about
day to day we're like hold on it's
actually
not that big of a deal so it's all about
sort of just looking at the glass
half full 100 no there was i see like
you got your little sfk kaleidoscope and
just like twist it
right i mean like like how can you see
something in a way that's like
ah like well because i got rejected from
this it led me and i i didn't audition
for like a hosting role
in la like um next time i'm coming to
light world obviously i'll hang out
of course yeah without a doubt i
went to la totally [ __ ] up the
teleprompter
literally like i have a video because i
talk to myself all the time sobbing like
like and i was like i'm the worst like
this was my one opportunity
in life and i messed it up i looked back
and i'm like first of all that show that
i audition for is cancelled
second of all if i was on that show i
would have been a part of another brand
when i really
truly always wanted to start my own and
i wouldn't have done that so
best thing to ever happen to me
everything happens for a reason
everything and you can't see it in the
moment but you've got to try it's like
you got to just be like okay
like i know there's an answer for why
this is happening i just don't know
right in this moment but it's going to
be good
were you raised to have this confidence
or were you just in
inherently already like i
i own my worth i know who i am i read
this like quote the other day because
like do not fear failure but be
terrified and regret
and i'm definitely a person that like
overthinks things and gets
really stressed out about the little
bits and pieces of everything and i
don't even really look at the big
picture of what i want
and i feel like that obviously for me it
will take time to like really build up
that
major confidence did you already just
have that and like you already knew at a
young age like this is me
okay well this is what i'm going to tell
you one i'm a confidence coach so
we can whenever you want i'm going to oh
my gosh
please i just did one with a 57 year old
and she literally started crying
like you said you were gonna mind [ __ ]
me and you did and i was like i know
that's good i'm gonna tell you this you
were born with confidence everyone's one
of the comments think about when you
were like four years old you were like
on the playground wherever the [ __ ] you
were you were like hey
like you were the problem is like when
we become older and we become aware
and perceptive about the world in our
place and what we should be like what we
should look like who we are
who our parents are things they tell us
that's when we
tend to get infected in a way especially
being a woman right right
it's very difficult so we tend to like
be very self-conscious and think like
are they judging me or what am i doing
this
you know and it's like it's not real
right like
you are really truly incredible the way
you are and anything that you do in life
is gonna lead you to the next best thing
and again what is the worst thing that
can happen
right crying that's right
like living your life fully and
realizing too
that a mistake isn't a mistake it's a
lesson right because like whenever we
[ __ ] up we're like okay we won't do that
again
right how to [ __ ] up to know that that's
true
my heart feels full like literally i'm
listening to you right now and
this is the [ __ ] that i actually need to
hear and i never tell myself any of this
right now
um i definitely want to get into the
confidence coach
yeah yeah i i want to know did you sort
were you self-taught in learning about
all of this or i mean how did you even
stumble upon this
becoming a confidence coach to exactly
what you're saying like
i was like getting dms all the damn time
and i was like what's responding
and i was like okay like it was also
like you know someone's like
my ex broke up with me and like it was
just it was i was like i need to talk to
you face-to-face so i actually was like
facetiming with a couple people in my
dms
and then i was like i'm gonna just like
start charging people for this
time of money honey oh yeah okay oh yeah
we never got to know our words as women
especially
so i was like i'm gonna start charging
people and then i kind of was like i'm
just gonna throw a link like link in bio
but like
not gonna announce it because part of me
was like
self-doubt i'm not a life coach i'm not
a therapist but i'm not claiming to be
i was like the confidence coach doesn't
exist but it does now
again right what is the worst thing that
can happen no one signs up okay
no one's thinking about you that's the
thing too
no one gives a [ __ ] about you what do
you want to do it one more time for the
people in the back
no one gives a [ __ ] about you their only
thing thank you all the time
oh my mom tells me this all the time she
goes girls
you are not special you're special to me
and your dad and your sister and the
dogs
no one else cares if you're wearing a
yellow top
or a white top today no one gives a [ __ ]
oh my god continue deliberating right
it's liberating
what's like what's really quick what's
something common that you see with
working with a ton of people in
confidence that it's been like
the trend of all of the people because i
feel like there's something probably
that everyone
has in common with having a confidence
problem
yeah i think really honestly like it's
because
we don't develop we don't nurture the
relationship with ourselves the way we
near to the relationship with our
siblings our parents our friends we what
do we do with them we hype them up we
tell them we love them we like we're
like we're so proud of you
we don't ever do that to ourselves yeah
i'm playing this woman i just coached
before this call
57 i said when's the last time you
talked to yourself and then you talked
to your best friend in the mirror
she goes never i go you've been
neglecting her for this
long i was like let's because think
about it like that person's with you
your whole damn life
yeah and they need that love and support
and the second you start doing that the
problem is it's like what i realized
when i
went into it's not that i by the way i
don't pay attention what anyone else is
doing
their confidence coach great i don't i
don't care like i'm not this is that
this is my thing and this is
what i do but like what i notice is a
lot of the like
live laughs love yourself like like i
love my flaws like that doesn't work
very surface means a dialogue
a conversation i talk to my best friends
all the time i'm an only child i talk to
the wall
so i was like [ __ ] i could talk to the
mirror now right right
about having that relationship with
yourself so that comes up a lot because
people are like i'm so insecure i'm not
really confident i'm like have you ever
really looked at yourself
and said hey like i love you i'm proud
of you thank you for being with me my
whole life
would you say that's something that
someone should do like people at home or
someone's listening everyone
everyone is that like the first thing
you will tell someone like at home
is the thing that will make you
confident
and by the way like it's free
that's true it's like it's kind of crazy
how simple it is
and but it's so important and actually
not enough women or men or anyone and i
just feel like not enough people are
doing this
i'm certainly not doing this and i know
if i had 10 minutes of your time
confidence coaching i'd probably be
wailing in the corner yeah
is that some of my clients are like i
try to do it but it was hard or like
i couldn't do it that's me but that's
but i know
i know ab punches like right it's hard
yeah you got to work that muscle and
it's always in different areas i feel
like people
do have confidence in some like for me
i'm confident when i'm dating someone
because i'm like you know
if they're not worth my time like i'm
not going to go with them but it's
usually within a career or
sometimes like with myself and do a lot
of people have it overall in every area
or do you think do you see it in like in
specific
areas of their life that they're like
lacking that extra confidence they need
first of all you should be [ __ ]
common careers look at what you're doing
so thank you i overthink that's my
problem
not anymore not something else to talk
about get to decide the narrative of who
you are
right so instead of being like i
overthink you're like i'm very
thoughtful
positive and i'm going to try to let go
a little more
right yeah oh my honestly
i've been to there before you're helping
me out with me before sophia
and i literally had a whole discussion
this morning about how she was
overthinking
a text message and and this is what you
need to hear
i just thought because you're careful of
that person's feelings right yeah
but the people that love you and care
about you a text message
a screaming that it's not gonna impact
your identity and who you are and what
they think of you
right because the people that love you
like me my roommate like she's known me
my whole she's known me forever
literally since like middle school
and there's sometimes like where i'm
screaming crying crazy and i'm like i'm
so sorry i was so crazy and she was like
i love you like you're allowed like your
last thing
isn't going to change everything right
one text is not
that's what's worth amen and again
you do not want what doesn't want you so
if you text someone and they don't text
you back [ __ ] them you didn't want to
hang out with them anyway
so trust me it's uh
okay so i think um i think i should
describe you
as being the main character of your life
you
own me you use main character complex
actually can you do you have a good
definition of what main character
complex is for people that don't know
what it is
this is what i say i say this is the
movie of your life
you are the star and i'm sitting here
eating popcorn watching what are you
gonna do
and that's the thing about the the the
overthinking comment it's like
you really get to decide your narrative
so
what you're right you might be more
thoughtful and a little more but
you you can change it from a negative to
a positive and you can be like okay
i tend to be very thoughtful about the
text because they want people to be
happy by the way is women were nurturers
because biologically
right yeah so you're more likely than
men so like
men will they were hunters right they go
head first into conflict
so that's why they'll go for that race
they'll go for things that they don't
qualify for because
they don't mind that conversation or
conflict right yeah
uncertainty too right because they would
go like hunt for things like yeah
whereas women were like babies
everyone has to be fed taken care of and
slept so that's why that that
overthinking things comes from because
you genuinely
care yeah but if you turn that into a
positive
and realize like sometimes i over
sometimes i think a lot
but i'm gonna do it less again that's
you're rewriting your movie yeah you're
rewriting
from a negative to a positive and also
control you have control to be like
[ __ ] it i'm going to send the text
you're so right and you know what's kind
of interesting i've been watching
so i don't know why i'm on tick tock i
shouldn't be but i'm on tick tock
are you on tick tock okay because i i
love it and so what i've seen actually
lately a lot of these girls doing is
are you the main character of your life
and they do like five fingers down like
or whatever like they'll list things off
and it's really sad because you'll see a
lot of girls they'll only put like four
fingers like i'm not the main character
i'm the sidekick
and it's like you're reinforcing that
you're not the star of your own life you
have this one life this one chance to
make a name for yourself or at least
make it
how you want to in your life and you're
already thinking
in such a negative negative way so of
course like if you think of yourself in
a negative way things around you are
going to be like that as well
and so i it's sad because young girls
are starting to do this even boys at a
age like that no but i was so insecure
and little and
what i'm going to do i'm going to go on
tick tock i'm going to reach out to all
of them and
mine [ __ ] them a little bit because
right i didn't have someone like me when
i was my age you know
so i like i think that's part of the
reason i do it like i had a great mom
who was
kind of like what your mom is talking to
you guys about like i but when it's your
mom it's like it's so [ __ ] like
you're
like i'm half of you you have to like
you have to say yeah you have to say i'm
pretty you have to tell me i'm amazing
but like yeah sorry not that convincing
no it's true it's true good actor mom
but like i think that for me i'm like oh
like i think that when i talk to people
or even you guys are like wow
i'm not saying anything that origin and
maybe it's the way i say it obviously
the [ __ ] adds a little like crit to
everything but like
what i'm interested i think hearing it
from someone else and also someone who's
young
and like was insecure and found a way to
be confident that
works could literally work for everyone
that's inspiring and especially in this
generation
it's totally different with social media
and then we have all of these platforms
that it's so easy to get caught up and
compare yourself to everybody else and
then think
oh my god this person is like rocking
their world and this person has an
amazing body but
and like talking to you and it's like
you get it because you're
being raised in this era right right
just a realist
information is all fake yeah and it
sucks but this is the thing the flip
side of social media too is that
there's so many like a young girl could
find me from in like kansas right or
like they could like listen to your
podcast and like
that access is also really beneficial
someone that might not grow up somewhere
with their sex education could suddenly
like
google it and know what the [ __ ] you
know so there's obviously
there's negatives and positives but
that's why it's so good for women to be
involved because furnitures and we care
and we'll educate right i mean you said
that there was
no one when you were growing up that
is basically you and i would say that me
growing up
you're the only version of that so thank
you
that i mean like you're saying a lot of
things that
i know it's so easy to be like well we
all know this it's all in us it's
you know all you have to do is say it
but it's really hard you know because
again i think it does have to do with
social media and constantly comparing
yourself and constantly
sophie and i are so terrible with the
amount of pressure that we just put on
our shoulders thinking that we should be
doing more
we should have achieved more both of our
parents had achieved
such success and i'm like what what are
we doing what are we doing wrong why
haven't we figured it out so it's really
nice
and reassuring um to hear you talk about
this
i'm so glad and by the way like you're
doing fantastic and
again when this calls over write down
like what
would excite you what is something you
know you don't have to know how you're
going to get there
but just really like what like would be
your dream
thing you know and if you don't really
know it's okay to be like i want to
start a podcast i want to have a show i
don't know what the [ __ ] out just
right so it's like and by the way this
is a major accomplishment what you guys
are doing is fantastic
so thank you celebrate the wins i know
we
we need to give ourselves a little bit
more credit sometimes because i think
we're always like oh my god we're not
doing enough and i feel like that's the
problems i especially we're always
wanting things instantaneously or want
things to like really succeed
right off the bat but we have to
remember that things take time like not
everything is going to be handed to you
not everything's going to
be 100 even if we come from two
pretty famous parents it doesn't mean
that it's going to work out for us like
we have to work just as hard but i think
that's
that's just something that we need to
work on ourselves when it comes to like
how many people don't have that outlook
that are entitled and like are like
what that is that's true that was our
biggest thing was like we never want to
be
those kids that like were raised in like
such a privileged home and not
put in like the work and get our asses
out there and like
write everything like we sit up like
writing these episodes we research the
hell out of you we like no we want to
make sure we come in here with good
questions
i've been on a lot of podcasts and they
don't i've noticed that you guys came
super prepared
and that makes sense for such a no
seriously i do a lot of progress
like did the work and like look at how
profound our conversation is because you
put in that effort right thank you thank
you i sort of want to jump back a little
bit
to your college days when you owned the
[ __ ] middle name
oh god so um
what was there a moment in college or a
story that you can think of that you
sort of just
switched because you said that you used
to be very insecure and
you were you're very reserved sort of
quiet kept to yourself what sort of
switch went off in your head that you're
like not anymore was there like a story
a moment a conversation you had
it was really just okay it was really i
remember was the first week of college
and
i felt like my two best friends were
like
super skinny like wearing matching like
tight body con
stripe dresses like couldn't be a worse
look for me at the time like i was like
no it looks good and strong right like
no one like no
but like and they actually were idiots
but does this matter but like the
they look they look taught and like all
the lacrosse guys were like they meet up
with three guys
and i just was like in my dorm like just
like
and then i was like i was like i cannot
believe
i'm letting what i
perceive to be the opinion of someone
else dictate the identity of who i am
i don't even know no one's called me
ugly no one called me this don't call me
fat what
whatever don't call me like oh like but
even just the thought that they might
i was letting that right before no way
i was like nope no like no
i don't see you did that confidence once
you hit that moment
do you think that it changed you
internally and externally like the way
you presented yourselves the way you
dress the way you
probably dyed your hair like anything
like that i think that in the beginning
when i did the sfk thing
it was like i wasn't i did it and like i
it's been a bit of a while i'm not like
that all but like it's like so i've had
a lot of time to think about why did it
like i don't think i was very
conscious of do what i was like i'm
insecure i want to be confident that's
what i'm gonna do
right i was just like i need some kind
of reminder like you're the [ __ ] like
let's go
and i think it took time it took time i
used to be a crutch like guys i couldn't
i literally could not introduce myself
without being like i'm sorry i [ __ ]
care again like
put on my resume like i was [ __ ] i put
it like you put it on your resume
and how was that perceived oh my gosh i
was like this is my brand
i'm like i want to go to media so like
it kind of worked oh yeah they love that
i
think with a crown like on my i'm
literally excited go girl
no i know that's amazing right i'm not
on the [ __ ] but anyway so it's like
it's just you know like but it took time
it took it took time to really
unders like to tap again tapping back
into it's like same thing lady gaga does
it's the same thing beyonce sasha
appears it says
persona like sfk is like extra like
large in life like makes the sidewalk a
red carpet like that's who sfp was she
became like this character that i kept
tapping into and eventually like
i could just be like hey i'm serena
because i feel her in me like we became
one right
when you gain this confidence i no doubt
people are probably
not always like the biggest fan of
someone that's because some people are
insecure and when they see someone that
has a lot of confidence
they can project their insecurities onto
you did you how do you deal with the
people that are
against this whole thing that you're
coming off as which is um well i think
is amazing but i can see where people
would be like
oh like she's just chatting they want to
play yeah
first of all [ __ ] that because the
people in my life
that love it it's obviously easier said
than done but truthfully you're not
gonna i used to be someone that wanted
to be led by everyone and that is so
exhausting because
you want to be like by everyone then who
are you you're like what is your
identity like you're not like you can't
no one can possibly be liked by everyone
no but the most important thing is
to like yourself so when you start to
like yourself people are attracted to
confidence and people want to be around
you
and those people in my life that want
the best for me will give me
constructive criticism and i'll ask them
like hey like
is this funny like or like did i [ __ ] up
here
they might even say like take down that
story like that that was too much you
know what i mean by like but why but why
do i listen them because they want the
best for me they're not always right but
like
they're giving me constructive criticism
all the people that by the way people
this happens all the time people look at
me being like i hated you at first and
then i got to know you
i wanted that too all the people that
didn't get to know me
i'm gonna [ __ ] about you that's not my
problem your work
you didn't do the work right and by the
way it's always about them
because right because they're not
thinking about us they think about that
yeah always about their insecurity it's
always like
and a lot of it was like it really like
was like a jolt to see someone so
confident and i realized that it was
like i was insecure and it was like i
was envious whatever and i was like
like there's a seat for you on my throne
like we can do this you know what i mean
like can you save can you save a seat
for sofia and i on your throne
y'all be you're running on my throne yay
serena i just want to thank you so much
i feel like i gained a new friend today
i know sophia can agree
i i seriously i feel like i've known you
my whole life this is a conversation
that i think
i definitely needed to have needed to
hear and i'm really excited for our
listeners to hear
you are one of the realest people i
don't think i've ever clicked with
anyone so quickly
i can't wait to freaking hug you when
you come to my life oh my god
i'm i'm like so i know it's so la
she's wearing a john and vinnie's hoodie
i mean it seems like friendship
starting
my show is premiering 9 9 wednesday 8 30
eastern 5 30 pacific um
and i want you guys to come on the after
show please please
absolutely you guys everyone listening
to what we must go on the live
check it out if you guys don't know
serena [ __ ] kerrigan
now you do we're gonna watch your show i
want all of the listeners to be
commenting non-stop
we absolutely love you thank you so much
so much could we like to start your chat
like i want to like chat
yeah like 100 absolutely yes but plug
all your socials before you leave
serena [ __ ] kerrigan let's [ __ ] go
that's actually the name of my company
literally are you
the best
everywhere dm me confidence coach watch
my show
just be happy because life is too short
not to be honestly hey
start awesome talking yourself in the
mirror every day i love it i will start
doing it
i love you hi i love you thank you for
coming on
from all of us here at the show thanks
for staying on wax
be sure to
or download follow your hosts at sophia
stallone
and at sistine stallone and be sure to
follow the show at unwaxed podcast
your producer is will sterling we'll see
you next week
you